à tous merci de nous retrouver sur
Public Sénat alors que la tuerie de
Newton qui a fait 20 morts dans une
école du Connecticut a relancé le débat
sur le contrôle des armes aux États-Unis
je vous propose ce matin de suivre un
cololloque qui s'est tenu mardi 18
décembre au Sénat à l'initiative de la
mission de la culture mais aussi de
l'Assemblée parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe sur la violence dans les médias
audiovisuels et ses conséquences sur les
enfants et la société bonne matinée à
tous mesdames messieurs je suis
particulièrement heureuse
d' de la culture de la science de
l'éducation et des médias de l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l' Europe
pour une réunion conjointe de nos deux
commissions sur le thème de la violence
dans les médias audiovisuell et ses
conséquences sur les enfants et la
société je voudrais saluer l'initiative
prise par Madame marieonne Blondin
auprès des instances du Conseil de
l'Europe pour la tenue de cette réunion
dans l'enceinte du Sénat c'est une
occasion de rassem
comme l'avait d'ailleurs déjà initié
Monsieur Jacques Leandre au sein d'un
parlement
national pour une réflexion commune les
membres d'une de ces commissions avec
des parlementaires du Conseil de
l'Europe je vous indique que cette
audition est ouverte à la presse et sera
retransmise sur
public
images et aux scènes de violence dans
les médias dont les enfants et les
adolescents peuvent être à la fois
spectateur et acteurs se pose avec
d'autant plus
d'acuité que le temps moyen passé devant
les écrans téléviseur tablette
ordinateur smartphone jeux vidéo ne
cessent de s'allonger et que les
évolution technologique amplifie leur
présence au sein des
familles un rapport du
Sénat écrit par Monsieur David Assouline
avait d'ailleurs signalé ses rapports
entre la jeunesse et Internet selon une
récente étude britannique le jour de ces
18 ans un jeune aura passé TR années
pleines jour et nuit devant un écran
quotidiennement dè l'âge de son entrée à
l'école l'enfant consacre 5 he en
moyenne aux écrans
aujourd'hui la régulation qui encadre
les programmes de la
télévision ne peut cependant entraver
la demander à tous les candidats je cite
de s'engager à abroger l'article 14 de
la loi du 16 juillet 1949 sur
publications destinées à la jeunesse qui
permet à notre ministre de
l'Intérieur de censurer la littérature
au prétexte de la protection de
l'enfance peu adepte de la censure nous
nous interrogions
cependant sur notre responsabilité
publique à donné à voir chaque jour des
coups des meurtres des des viols et
autres assassinats à
répétition
du Comité des Ministres du Conseil de
l'Europe de même que mon que mon
collègue l'ambassadeur rinozi et
aussi on m'a demandé donc d'être un peu
le le modérateur de cette première
partie de la
session qui concerne la violence dans
les médias à partir des des ancien au je
jusqu'au jeux interactifs en trois
dimensions nous allons écouter des
experts qui auront certainement des
choses beaucoup plus intéressantes à
vous dire
euhqu se tient dans ses propos la
violence dans les médias est aussi
vieille que les médias mais la
consommation de contenus médiatique
violent et banalisant la violence a
énormément augmenté avec lesessorts de
la télévision numérique la pénétration
forte du marché des médias par
l'Internet et la diffusion des jeux
interactifs y compris en ligne une
étudeé une étude menée au Portugal en
2000action violente et 2205 décès par
mois suite à une exposition moyenne de
2h et dem de télévision par jour en
outre la violence avait été
particulièrement forte dans les films et
les dessins animés les programmes pour
les enfants avaient un taux plus élevé
de violence
que ceux destinés aux adultes il a été
observé que la violence télévisée au
Portugal le Comité des Ministres du
Conseil de l'Europe a abordé la question
de la violence dans les médias en
1997 dans sa recommandation 9719 sur la
représentation de la violence dans les
médias électroniques que vous pourrez
évidemment
consulter depuis cette recommandation 15
ans sont passés et les médias
d'aujourd'hui sont très différents cette
recommandation du Comité des Ministres
reste valable
en en tenant compte du contexte
actuel le Comité des Ministres s'est
penché plus avant sur la question de
l'incidence des nouveaux médias à
l'égard des mineurs sur leur protection
et leur responsabilisation il a adopté
en la matière la recommandation cm REC
20095 visant à protéger les enfants
contre les contenu
et le comportement préjudiciable et à
promouvoir leur participation active au
nouvel environnement de l'information
et
je j'ai déjà salué monsieur renoui
vice-président de l'Assemblée
parlementaire et président de la
délégation française néanmoins euh il y
a eu un il fit un petit
euh à Monsieur roué et donc je veux pas
du tout euh
empêcher monsieur roué bien au contraire
nous sommes très très intéressés à
l'entendre donc euh
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur on
a deeurope l'habitude de partager la
tribune avec le Conseil des Conseil des
Ministres du
Conseil madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président mes chers mesdames Messieurs
chers collègues pour beaucoup d'entre
vous puisque vous savez que j'ai été
quelques temps dans cette assemblée au
Sénat je suis maintenant député et
surtout je voudrais saluer mes collègues
qui sont dans ma la délégation du
Conseil de l'Europe avec moi
permettez-moi d'ouvrir mon propos en
vous faisant part des excuses de
Jean-Claude pour être présent parmi nous
cet après-midi en raison des nombreuses
obligations qu'appelle sa prés
et croyez-moi monsieur mignon est très
présent il est actuellement est très
présent et très actif au Conseil de
l'Europe il est actuellement avec en
Moldavie où il essae de faire avancer
cette zone ce conflit gelé et il
rencontre d'ailleurs les autres
autorités de Moldavie je crois qu'il
voit le président de la République cet
après-midi ce n'est assurément pas parce
qu'il tiendrait pour
négligeables j qui nous rassemble la
violence dans les
médias plus largement les questions de
société touchant à l'enfance et la
jeunesse bien au contraire Jean pour
preuve la participation du président
mignon à la deè conférence du Conseil de
l'Europe des ministres responsables de
la jeunesse qui s'est tenu il y a
quelques temps à Saint-Pétersbourg au
mois de septembre dernier et dont il a
d'ailleurs regretté et nous l'a fait
savoir qu'il na pu adopter une
déclaration finale je veux rappeler
aussi son son implication dans les
préparations et le déroulement de
l'assemblée des jeunes qui a eu lieu
en de vous transmettre ses vœux les plus
chaleureux de réussite
comment les images et messages violents
de toute nature dont sont environnés les
enfants et les adolescents
interfèrent-ils avec leur comportement
de tels messages sont-ils déterminants
dans le passage à l'acte et notamment le
passage à l'acte violent voire à l'acte
délinquant quelle réponse est-il
possible d'apporter à de telles
interrogations dans le domaine précis de
la protection de l'enfance et
adolescence à toutes ces questions qui
pourraient former en quelqu
s le devoir d'apporter son éclairage
propre et la capacité de formuler des
proposition le Conseil de l'Europe a en
effet vocation à défendre et promouvoir
les droits de l'homme sur un continent
meurtri par l'histoire et chacun sait
combien les enfants qui sont parmi les
membres les plus vulnérables de nos
sociétés ont besoin d'une protection
particulière par ailleurs le Conseil de
l'Europe est une organisation
particulièrement car il peut mobiliser
facilement les quatre piliers de
l'action publique les gouvernement les
parlementaires les autorités locales et
les ONG il est en mesure de comin des
outils la définition de normes le suivi
des engagements des États-membres le
soutien ou politique national la
conception et la mise en place de
programmes de coopération et
d'assistance ainsi que d'activités
d'éducation de formation et de
communication plusieurs initiatives ont
été lancées ces dernières années au
premier rang desquels je dois mentionner
le programme transversal construire une
Europe pour et avec les enfants qui a
été lancé en 2006 je ne peux également
pas manquer de faire mention de la
campagne 1/ 5 qui vise à lutter contre
la violence sexuelle à l'égard des
enfants et qui a été mis en place à la
fin de l'année 2010 dans ce cadre
général l'initiative conjointe de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication du Sénat français
et de la commission de la culture de la
science de l'éducation et des Médi
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe est
tout à fait bienvenue l'évolution des
médias depuis une quinzaine d'années a
vu l'arrivée en masse et les
généralisation de contenu présenté de
façon répétée et intense qui véhicule
souvent un climat d'agression de
sexualisation et de domination des
personnes la violence dans les divers
médias qu'il s'agisse de la la radio la
télévision de la presse écrite des jeux
vidéos et plus récemment d'Internet
suscite des débats récurrents à propos
de ses effets éventuels sur les
spectateurs et lecteurs en particulier
les plus jeunes d'entre eux diverses
études menées en France en particulier
par le Conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel ont montré qu'un enfant
peut assister à de très nombreuses
séquences violentes CRIM ou agression
par heure de fiction télévisée et qu'un
grand nombre des émissions pour enfants
et de jeux vidéo reposent sur des
scénario de violence dans lesquels la
survie du héros et des affrontements
physiques constituent la trame de
l'histoire c'est donc par l'impact d'un
environnement violent qu'il faut
analyser et non pas l'influence d'un
médiat particulier c'est ainsi c'est
aussi de messages qu'il convient de
parler tout autant que d'images
violentes d'blé un malaise peut
s'installer faut-il bannir toute forme
de
violence par les enfants et ceux qui ne
le seraient pas entre ceux qui seraient
explicable parce que situé dans un
contexte et expliqué par des personnes
entourant
l'enfant réductible à toute entreprise
d'interprétation en fonction du degré de
maturité de ceux auquel il s'adresse la
violence est-elle un mal absolu qui
appelle à une protection absolue ou un
processus de construction sociale qui
doit être accepté comme tel à condition
d'être bien entendu maîtrisé on
peut-être étonné si on se place dans le
temps long de l'histoire de voir qu' des
siècles les rapports humains
apparaissent progressivement comme moins
brutaux dans la vie quotidienne des
sociétés européennes aussi l'Europe
moderne puis contemporaine a su faire
émerger un modèle de gestion de la
violence qui parvient progressivement à
canaliser les pulsions agressives
individuelles qui sont essentiellement
le fait des hommes jeunes parallèlement
se sont
diffusés à une dévalorisation de plus en
plus forte de la brutalité mais aussi
une littérature noire du frisson et du
crime qui a installé le phénomène de
violence a pris place à côté des faits
réels de violence et a offert un
dérivatif un exutoire que d'cin ont pu
voir comme ayant permis de pacifier
progressivement les murs assistons-nous
aujourd'hui avec l'explosion
d'Internet avec la multiplication des
chaînes de télévision avec le
développement des réseaux sociaux un
changement de paradigme ou à une simple
approfondissement des tendances
préexistantes vos débats l'évoqueront
certainement la violence médiatique
a-t-elle des vertus
catardiques participe-t-elle d'un vaste
rit social auquel chacun devrait
sacrifier dans une sorte de processus
initiatique qui ferait passer de l'
enfance à l'âge adulte je ne peux
manquer de constater que face à l'offre
de violence qui défer dans les médias il
y a aussi une demande de violence dont
témoigne certains succès commerciaux des
films qui trouvent leur public des jeux
qui trouvent leur communauté et cetera
de exemples
brièvement une étude récente visant à
quantifier les scènes de violence dans
les films qui depuis 50 ans nous compte
les aventures d'un célèbre agent secret
de Sa Gracieuse Majesté montre que si
les indicateurs de la violence
légère ont plus que doublé entre les
premiers et les derniers films or le
succès de cette série cinématographique
ne se dément pourtant pas bien au
contraire le journal
2è
tir des zombies et de la magie on y
apprend que pour l'un des jeux analysés
l'île où le héros a débarqué et
n'oubliez pas que les héros bien sûr
c'est nous c'est vous s'avè contrôlé par
des pirates trafiquant barbares et
autres fous psychopathes sanguinaires
qui auront au fait de capturer vos amis
mais rassurez-vous car est-il dit plus
loin dans l'article l'armement est
impressionnant l'appréciation
finaleidire du grand art que dire de
cette démarche si ce n'est qu'au
supermarché de la violence l'horreur
devient une denrée banale cet équilibre
de marché entre une offre et une demande
de violence doit nous interpeller car de
l'
mon propos en demandant s'il est
légitime ou pas de distinguer la
violence du monde réel donné à voir dans
les médias et la violence artificielle
créée et mise en scène pour elle les
échanges que nous aurons aujourd'hui
permettront j'en suis certain d'aller
bien plus loin dans que ces réflexions
liminires même s'ils n'ont pas vocation
à apporter des réponses définitives et
des recettes toutes faites je suis
convaincu que votre travaux nos travaux
apporteront une contribution importante
à la protection des enfants contre la
violence et aux actions entrepris en ce
sens par les organisations
internationales et les autorités
nationales de nos pays démocratiques je
n'oublie pas en effet que pour les
sociétés non démocratiques la violence
est un moyen mais pour les sociétés
démocratiques la violence est un
problème nous sommes ici des
responsables politiques
venant de tous les horizons il nous
appartient de prendre à bras le corp ce
problème de l'exposition des enfants à
la violence dans les médias c'est notre
mission merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président de ma délégation c'est un très
grand plaisir de vous recevoir et je j'y
associe Jacques lejandre et et Bernard
Fournier qui sont ici présents et qui
ont été aussi avec moi et bien le petit
aiguillon pour demander à ce que nous
nous nous réunissions que
vous concrètement au Conseil de l'Europe
et je suis très heureuse et nous sommes
très heureux de vous accueillir ici au
Sénat alors j'ai regardé un petit peu
évidemment la liste impressionnante des
intervenants et des experts et nous
sommes là pour cela
alors nous allons leur donner leur
donner la parole mais je suis très
heureuse de rencontrer mon ami FGO parce
que nous nous sommes vu il y a pas très
longtemps ici en tant que groupe
d'amitié et puis et nous avons aussi une
capitale une capitale cul cultur dans
chacun de nos pays européennes dans
chacun de nos pays nous avons Marseille
et nous les membres de la commission
culture doivent se déplacer demain et
vous avez que je vais mal prononcer je
vais te laisser le soin de le prononcier
donc capitale également européenne
voilà et bien
alors coorda la prère
d'accord je vous donne la
parole
merci donc je tout je remercie monsieur
le vice-président de l'Assemblée
parlementaire pour son intervention qui
nous pose beaucoup de pistes de
réflexion et qui nous rappelle notre
président président mignon qui est
toujours
et que je je tiens particulièrement
aussi à saluer merci de votre
intervention
euh donc j'espère que les interventions
et le débat dans cette première session
donc il y a comme objet la violence dans
les médias à partir des dessins anciens
jusqu'aux jeux interactifs en trois
dimensions nous permettront de mieux
comprendre l'évolution du phénomène la
violence dans les médias et les formes
qu'elle assume dans les nouveaux médias
ainsi que de prendre conscience de
l'impact de cette violence sur les
enfants et notre société nous avons avec
nous trois experts qui ont fait
d'importantes ce domaine tout d'abord la
docteur Astrid siipfel de l'université
Heinrich hein du seldorf qui est
coauteur d'une vaste étude réalisée pour
le gouvernement allemand en 2004 madame
salumè Ramou ma compatriote psychologue
de l'université d'Ave au Portugal qui a
produit récemment une analyse
substantielle de la recherche sur les
médias Internet et Monsieur le
Professeur Joe Grebel directeur
scientifique de l'étude de l'UNESCO à
Berlin
qui madame la Présidente de donner la
parole à Madame tipfel
ensuite à Madame ramche et ensuite à
Monsieur le Professeur Grebel merci
au
ah merci
beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs bonjour je vous
remercie de l'invitation et de
l'occasion à parler à vous sur les
effets des médias audiovisuel sur les
enfants et la société
et j'aurais aimé continuer en français
mais je pense que pour que l'on me
comprenne mieux je devrais passer à
l'anglais la violence a toujours attiré
l'attention toujours exerc une tion
particulier particulière depuis que les
médias
maintenant il y a eu beaucoup de
discussions beaucoup de
d'études empiriqu sur ces sujets le
débat a toujours été empreint d'émotion
et aujourd'hui il y a très peu de savoir
scientifique il y a plus de discussions
plutôt émotiv sur ce sujet donc
aujourd'hui j'ai la possibilité c'est
pour moi un plaisir de vous faire part
d'un certain nombre d'études empiriques
sur le sujet et de vous faire part de ce
que la science a apporté à ce sujet
source d'émotion encore une
fois alors cela s'applique évidemment à
différents types de médias même si la
grande majorité des études se sont porté
sur la violence dans les médias
audiovisuels alabord quelqu information
sur les jeux vidéo sur la violence dans
les jeux vidéo qui sont au centre
des des études
actuelles ce que je vais vous
présenter est une sorte de compilation
de synthèse effectué par le professeur
Michael professeurér de l'université
dere serviteur de l'Université
de je TR pour minre
de la famille des personnes âgées des
femmes et de la jeunesse alors ces
résultats sont très diversifiés sont
parfois même contradictoires ne
permettent pas d'arriver à des
conclusions simples et univoqu la
complexité est peut-être d au fait que
les scientifiques les chercheurs
se se concentrent sur des mécanismes et
sur des effets très
diversifi alors on peut
ou de cognition ou d'attitude cognitive
qui serait à l'origine de la violence
j'ai très peu de temps donc je vais pas
vous présenter en détail toutes les
théories vous en trouverez dans mon
exposé par par écrit je vais quand même
vous dire quelques mots si vous me le
permettez sur les grandes approches les
grands modèles à notre disposition tout
d'abord je
voudrais commencer par deux approches
assez ancienes qui ont é réfuté
maintenant par la science mais on ne
peut pas les éliminer de la discussion
publique la première c'est la théorie de
la catarcis elle affirme
que le visionnage de contenu violent
permet de fantasmer fantasmer la
violence il s'agit d'une décharge
fantasmée qui évite qui évite de passer
à l'acte alors il n'y a pas
véritablement de d'études
directement ce qu'ils ont vu à l'écran
alors c n'explique pas les mécanismes
sous-jacents à ce mécanisme des cas de
contagion de suicide
cependant cela n'arrive que dans des
conditions tout à fait spécifiques et le
contenu des médias ne semble que l'une
des causes parmi d'autres ou une sorte
de déclencheur finale d'une action qui a
été planifiée depuis longtemps et donc
ces sont mieux expliqués par des
théories plus différenciées une troisème
théorie c'est la théorie de
l'habituation de la désensibilisation
qui fait l'objet de beaucoup de
discussions et les gens euh deviennent
de plus en plus insensibles à la
brutalité
des des chercheurs ont
étudié C ces phénomènes et se sont
aperçu que les émotions des personnes
qui avaient visionné du contenu violent
ces émotions étaient atténué ou émoussé
mais cela aurait
un on ne sait pas véritablement si cela
a une influence sur l'attitude envers la
violence dans la vie réelle si cela
diminue l'empathie pour les victimes de
violence dans la vie réelle et si cela
diminue le
seil théorie de l'apprentissage social
de la
culture on peut observer un certain
nombre
d'actions dans les médias ou dans la vie
réelle et ainsi les sujets apprennent en
Obs
il faut quand même ajouter que
d'habitude ces moyens de communication
sont plutôt latin et ne font pas pardon
ne font pas l'objet de de passage à
l'acte tout simplement parce que à cause
de la peur d'être sanctionné et le
transfert le passage à des actions
manifestes et le
processus le processus d'apprentissage
sont
encouragés par un certain nombre
de tion
ou aux punition ou aux
sanctions donc il s'agit de d'action qui
qui porte à conséquence et par cela
selon les conséquences selon les
patterns de rétribution ou de sanction
les personnes apprennent alors voyons
maintenant quelle est la pertinence de
ces
effets en ayant étudié toute cette masse
d'étude et bien l'on voit que ce que
l'on ce que les les les faits les
preuves sont assez sont assez
faibles une personne est expliqué et par
les médias ceci a été
également corrobor corroboré par des
études à long terme
pourquoi
condition cela peut augmenter ou
diminuer cela signifie également que les
effets de la violence dans les médias
sont atténués ou sont pondéré par un
certain nombre de contenus les
caractéristiques de la violence les
caractéristiques personnelles d'un autre
côté quels sont les facteurs de risque
qui sont liés au contenu des des médias
d'après ce que l'on sait maintenant le
contexte de la description de la
violence est bien plus important
que l'intensité et les violences les
types de violen qui sont le plus à
risque sont les suivantes tout d'abord
les comportements violents et qui semble
justifiés ça peut être expliqué par la
théorie de l'apprentissage qui affirme
que la violence justifié attire beaucoup
plus
l'attention est un facteur motivation de
passage à l'acte deuxièmement un
deuxième facteur de risque si la
violence est du fait d'un protagoniste
attirant séduisant par quelqu'un qui
vous ressemble par
exemple trisièmement au troème facteur
de risque si la violence est récompensée
par une forme de succès ou au moins au
moins qu'elle ne fasse pas l'objet de
sanction né et
què autre facteur de risque si la
violence est banalisé c'està-dire qu'il
n'y a pas de conséquences négatives
visiblebl pour la victime si le
spectateur n'a aucune raison d'éprouver
de l'empathie pour la
victime en ce qui concerne les
caractéristiques des jeux vidéo et bien
la recherche et c'est intéressant de le
noter n'a pas véritablement de
avc un certain nombre
d'hypothèses que
ça que
l'on si l'on joue avec un personnage qui
vous ressemble par exemple cela ne
produit pas véritableblement d'ffits et
les jeux
vidéo a priori n'auraient pas plus
d'influence que d'autres contenus
violents par exemple la télévision en ce
qui concerne maintenant la personne le
sujet les effets de la
violence sont
plus il y a plus de risque qu'elle
qu'elles aient une influence si le sujet
est un garçon ou un homme s'il est
enfant
les enfants peuvent comprendre un
certain nombre d'histoires mais parfois
ils n'ont pas assez de d'assise Mor il n
pas assz d'élé pour juger du bien ou du
mal trè facteur c'est une
personne et
qui sensation ce sont des personnes qui
cherchent le risque qui cherche
l'excitation
4è 4è trait il s'agit de prédisposition
agressiv des personnes qui sont déjà
violentes et bien il recherch des
contenus
violents les études longitudinales
montrent quelque chose d'intéressant à
savoir que il y aurait
un un processus que qui a été qualifié
par certains chercheurs de modèle de la
spirale descendante c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a une sorte de spirale d'entraînement
entre une personnalité agressive et un
contenu violent c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
une sorte de cercle vicieux les
personnes qui sont déjà agressives
chercheront du contenu violent qui
augmentera leur tendance agressive donc
il y a une sorte de cercle vicieux et de
renforcement si on intervient au début
de la mise en place d'un certain nombre
de préférences dans le
psychismeisque de conséquences négatives
lié au contenu VI si les enfants vivent
dans une famille où il y a une grande
utilisation grande consommation de
contenu violent et si les
enfants
il considère comme des modèles c'est
pour cela
que il peut y avoir un renforcement un
renforcement entre différents éléments
et
donc il est important de se concentrer
sur
les
sur les aspects
suivants la grande majorité des
chercheurs sont d'accord pour dire que
la violence dans les médias a peu peu
provoquer des effets négatifs cependant
en général ces effets sont
faibles n'empêche pas que le contenu
violent peut sur certains individus
avoir un grand effet sur d'autres pas du
tout d'effet les chercheurs ont pu
identifier un certain nombre de facteurs
de risque liés au contexte dans lequel
cette violence est subie et mais c ces
facteurs ne sont pas dépendants les uns
des autres mais sont en interaction et
donc
les expérience de la violence dans la
vie réelle joue également un rôle très
très important
et les groupes à risque représente une
petite partie de la société et la
violence dans les médias sont un des
facteur un des facteurs parmi d'autres
qui peut représenter et qui peut
susciter de la violence chez certaines
personnes dans une société qui est déjà
violente je vous
remercie Monsieur l'Ambassadeur merci
madameipel et je passe maintenant la
parole à Madame Salom RAM du Portugal
qui nous va parler de la violence dans
les médias sur l'Internet contenu
violent et un comportement violent entre
les
utilisateurs c'est pour moi un grand
plaisir de vous faire part de certains
résultats d'une étude menée au
Portugal je ne vais pas vous présenter
la théorie vous l'avez dans les
documents
donc nous avons mené une étude
l'université d'avero avec
745 étudiants élèves
portugais il venaent du centre du
Portugal dans TR district et nous avons
sélectionné 12
écoles quelques caractéristiques de
notre échantillon il s'agissait d'élèves
entre 10 et 18 ans
82% av entre 12 et
l'échantillon était composé de 4
402 filles et
garçons comme vous pouvez le voir dans
vos
documents nous avons beaucoup travaillé
pour la configuration de cet échantillon
mais trouverez le détail dans le
document alors tout d'abord nous avons
essayer des élèves pouvaient regarder la
télévision dans le le salon 30 % avaient
une télévision dans leur propre chambre
97 % avait un téléphone portable à la
maison 77 % pouvaent l'utiliser à
l'extérieur
et ils étaient très intéressés par la
télévision par les téléphones portables
mais ils étaient encore plus intéressés
par internet et ils avaient une
connexion Internet pour 96 % d'entre eux
euh 39
% dans des pièces partagées par les
adultes par exemple le salon ou la
cuisine 57 % dans leur chambes pour 75 %
des élèves ils avaient accès à Internet
à l'extérieur en ce qui concerne le
temps passé bien 3h par jour en moyenne
pour lire des revues et
des et des livres 5h contre 5h par jour
pour tout ce qui est consacré à les
nouvelles technologie 5h par jour pour
la télévision 5h3 pour les téléphones
portables 4h pour Internet et de plus en
plus de garçons qui jouent à des jeux
vidéos le weekend les jeunes passent
jusqu'à 6h devant la télévision ou
devant des jeux vidéo avec une
utilisation d'innet de 5h en moyenne il
y a de plus en plus de nouvelles
technologies dans la vie des jeunes ils
sont de plus en plus accessibles et ils
sont
de
pass à consommer ces médiens ou aller
regarder et le comportement violent mais
certains pensent que ce temps peut être
associé au harcèlement ou au
cyberhcèlement dans les pendant la
semaine il semble qu'il y ait une
corrélation entre le temps passé devant
Internet par exemple devant la
télévision et la la télévision et le
harcèlement et encore plus quand
il
euh un grand nombre regarde des jeux
vidéo mais même si 19 % affirme
que tout comme le temps consacré aux
médias l'exposition à un contenu violent
est corrélé de façon positive avec
la des formes de harcèlement ou de
cyberhcèlement il
semble il semble que la corrélation soit
plus grande entre le temps passé à
l'utilisation de ces médias et le cyber
harcèlement et nous avons noté un
certain nombre de particularités
notamment
l'implication des parents l'implication
des parents dans le contrôle 82 % des
parents regardent la
télévision alors que seul 25 % des
parents suivent ce que les enfants font
sur
Internet 56 % des parents contrôlent le
temps que les enfants passent sur
Internet 44 % contrôle ce qu'ils font
sur Internet et 25 % sont avec eux les
accompagnent au moment où ils sont sur
Internet et 53 % parl avec que
d'Internet alors il devient de plus en
plus difficile pour les parents de
suivre la corrélation entre
l'implication des parents et
l'utilisation des médias et le
comportement violent cette
implication semble avoir une corrélation
négative avec le harcèlement et le
cyberhcèlement
alors même si la corrélation n'est pas
très très forte le contrôle est associé
en général avec une diminution de la
fréquence des comportements violents
même si on peut se poser la question de
l'efficacité du contrôle de la part des
parents par exemple on ne sait pas très
bien dans quelle mesure les parents
regarde du contenu violent avec leurs
enfants sans véritablement être
conscient de ce représenter comme
intensité de violence pour les enfants
ou même parfois parfois en se en
approuvant ces comportements violents en
ce qui concerne les attitudes justement
envers la violence il semble qu'il y ait
une forte
corrélation entre les formes violence
harcèlement passer à l'acte en France
cette étude montre qu'il y a une
relation entre le harcèlement et le
cyberharcèlement il semble qu'il y ait
une corrélation positive
entre entre ces deux entre ces deux
formes de comportement et la
corrélation pourrait nous faire penser à
une
probabilité un comportement violent avec
les enfin dans dans la classe dans la
vie réelle mais également sur sur
Internet quelques réflexions maintenant
sur ces résultats la
violence chez les enfants chez les
jeunes est un phénomène de plus en plus
visible dans nos sociétés on ne peut pas
lui attribuer une cause unique bien
évidemment et c'est bien pour cela que
la recherche doit
prie
pour mieux comprendre ce
phénomène étudier l'effet de la violence
dans les médias cela ne
peutichrichir le débat
sur façon
éclairée il y a un grand nombre de voies
de recherche sur la sur les médias sur
son influence sur ses conséquences pas
se for de violence
il est indispensable également d'étudier
tout ce qui tout ce qui a trait pardon à
la santé et au
risque au risque de
l'Internet que les enfants se servent
des médiens bon ce n'est pas d'après
nous la principale cause de la violence
l'évolution des
médias se passe à un rythme
effrainé mais en même temps
cel
comme jamais auparavant cependant il
faut que les enfants soient bien équipés
pour pouvoir répondre à ces nouvelles
possibilités aujourd'hui les médias
jouent le rôle d'éducateur ils
transmettent le savoir mais également
des attitudes et des valeurs et donc
cette possibilité de d'avoir un
contact monde
extérieur présente une chance inouï mais
également de grands risques les études
exploratoires notamment cell que je
viens de vous mentionner représente une
contribution parmi d'autres pour mieux
comprendre la violence chez la jeunesse
et nous pensons qu'il y a
un rôle tout à fait fondamental à jouer
pour les parents en tant que médiateur
et cette question doit être creusée doit
être recherchée ça c'est une des
premières conclusions qui plus il est
indispensable
également que les parents mais les
éducateurs les enseignants sachent
comment réagir à ces
phénomènes
sans arrivver à une meilleure
réglementation de la production
télévisuelle et de la de la production
sur internet qu'elle soit d'une
meilleure qualité mais ça ne suffit pas
il est indispensable également
d'apprendre aux gens à se servir des
médias
et il est indispensable nous semble-t-il
également cette étude d'élaborer des
programmes de sensibilisation de
formation pour les enfants pour les
jeunes pour les parents pour les
enseignants pour toutes les parties
prenantes pour leur apprendre à se
servir de ces nouvelles technologies il
est indispensable
tion de qui s'occupent des enfants pour
réduire pour réduire le temps passé
devant la télévision devant Internet
pour
M apprendre à se servir de ces médiens
pour assurer la promotion
d'attitude antiviolence pour condamner
la violence et pour adopter des
stratégies de résolution de problème
deçon mer vre
intervention vre contribtion à ce débat
et je passe la parole maintenant
à Monsieur le professeur grbel qui a été
le directeur de l'étude de l'UNESCO
l'étude mondiale de l'UNESCO sur la
violence dans les médias de 98 quel le
son apprise je donne donc la parole à
Monsieur le Professeur
Grebel
mesames et messieurs je m'excuse je ne
parle pas français je suis un barbare
allemand je
m'excuse je vais continuer en
anglais j'ai maîtriser la technologie
tout
d'abord
vous
voyez d'après mes cheveux
gris que je me préoccupe de la recherche
sur la violence dans les
médias
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit Madame tipel et également Ramos
les experts scientifiques sont sur la
même longueur d'onde donc après 40 ans
de recherche en matière de violence dans
les médias et avec mes cheveux gris
comme je l'ai dit parfois je suis un
petit peu làin de toutes
ces demandes en ce qui
concerne la sensibilisation sur la
violence dans les médias
l'autonomisation des parents et
cet je ne voudrais pas adresser de
critique tout tout toutes ces questions
sont fort importante mais parfois il me
semble qu'il faudrait s'arrêter essayer
de dresser un bilan il pour être un
petit peu provocateur polémique je
dirais que toute cette question de
violence dans les médias et cette
revendication d'éducation des parents en
la matière est-ce que tout ceci n'est
pas une sorte d'Ali pour dire bon nous
avons fait quelque chose nous demandons
plus d'éducation en matière de médiia et
puis basta nous passons à autre
chose al je ne sais pas si vous m'riez
invité si vous aviez su que j'allais
dire cela mais ceci dit j'ai quand même
des résultats que je voudrais évoquer
devant
vous il y a plus de 10 ans pour l'UNESCO
j'ai étudié cette question mais certains
des enseignements que j'ai pu en tirer
sont toujours valables maintenant j'ai
écouté les deux derniers orateurs et
cela m'a bien prouvé que mes recherches
étaient toujours valables essayons de
tout d'abord nous pencher sur certains
cas qui nous ont préoccupé par exemple
ce weekend la tuerie de Newtown 27
personnes surtout des enfants tués à
l'école la semaine passé av un suicide d
un cyberhcèlement ce qui est très triste
reprend exactement ce que vous
disiez dans votre intervention
aujourd'hui encore cinq personnes ont
été tué par les talibans au Pakistan
c'était des personnes travaillant pour
une association luttant contre la polio
alors qu'est-ce que toutes ces cas ont à
faire entre eux quel est le lien entre
toutes ces affaires nous y
reviendronsuss le suspense de mon
intervention quel est le le rôle donc
joué par les médias en la matière mais
pour revenir à l'intervention de Madame
tipel toutes ces
cas ne n aucune signification
statistique ne sont pas significatif du
point de vue statistique aux États-Unis
par an 30000 personnes sont tuées par
fusillade
c'est une centaine par jour
et pourtant ce n'est que une ou deux
fois par an que laattention du monde est
concentré sur ces événements par exemple
lorsque beaucoup d'enfants sont tués en
même temps ou lorsque les enfants sont
très jeunes statistiquement pourtant ces
accidents ces massacres n'ont pas de
signification statistique et pourtant
ils déclench le débat sur les médias la
violence dans les médias j'ai été invité
par l'acelier
schreduder pour rejoindre un panel
d'experts pour l'affaire steinhouser il
y a 10 ans il s'est agit d'un massacre
dans une école allemande avec 17
étudiants qui avaient été tués et
l'objet de ce panel était est-ce que les
médias ont joué un rôle en la matière or
en fait oui nous avons conclu que les
médias sont un facteur mais un des
facteurs dans des événements qui sont
multifactoriels alors je vais me
concentrer sur ma première
partie à savoir l'étude de l'UNESCO qui
a été publiée tout d'abord en 2001 et
qui a été conduite à la fin de 1998 et
99 jusqu'en
99 cette étude s'est penché sur l'impact
de
l'environnement du contexte culturel de
du milieu
culturel et comme vous l'avez dit tous
les deux l'expérience en matière de
violence vous avez également souligné
qu'il y avait des grospes par sur
lesquel nous devions nous
concentrer il s'agit pas en général de
groupe moyen même les sénateurs ont
parfois des enfants qui peuvent être
menacés par cette exposition à la
violence mais la probabilité est moindre
que l'impact soit délétaire que dans
unautres milieu
sociaux voilà quelques information de
base cette étude a été conduite pour
l'UNESCO
avec le mouvement de
SCO qui était une organisation mondiale
qui m'a beaucoup
aidé à l'époque professeur à re et nous
avons fait une enquête sur
5500 jeunes de 12 ans nous avons donc eu
un ge choisi un âge standard avec un
facteur d'âge qui serait
stable fixé à 12 ans et nous avonsl pays
dans le monde représentant toutes sortes
de
culture d'environnements
sociaux et
d'expériences différentes en matière de
violence ce que nous avons recherché
plus particulièrement comme vous l'avez
mentionné c'est d'étudier soutud les
structures familiales le soutien
familial les orientations les
valeurs
et
nous avons également étudié les
différences en valeurs et en orientation
religieuse le sexe également a joué un
rôle féminin ou masculin
et différenciation suivant le genre donc
et nous avons également étudié les
facteurs du média et le contrôle social
certains des résultats
brièvement la violence parle une langue
mial pas une
surprise la violence c'est quelque chose
que tout un
chacun la vi quelque chose à laquelle
tout un chacun s'intéresse soit parce
que il ou elle en a été victime soit
parce que il ou elle est attiré vers
cette violence de toute façon il s'agit
là d'une d'un fait archaïque nous devons
réagir à la violence nous'avons pas
besoin nécessairement de réagir à la
paix nous sommes obligés réagir à
l'agression et c'est pourquoi les médias
les loisirs s'intéressent à la violence
il peut y avoir bien sûr des
loisirs
paisibles mais physiologiquement parlant
nous sommes configurés de manière à
réagir à la violence à
l'agression et c'est la fait des
millénaires que nous avons appris que
l'agression est menaçante et que nous
devons y accorder toute notre attention
ne serait-ce que même sur un
écran dans notre étude englobant
5500 enfant dans le monde nous avons
constaté que la plupart de ces enfants
ou de ces étudiants de ces
écoliers connaissait les
mêmes vedett de
cinéma qui jouit dans les films violents
Schwarzer dans Terminator à l'époque et
ça on a en Afrique dans des régions
africaines qui n'avait qui avait très
peu de d'écrans de télévision ou aux
États-Unis ou la France
schwarzeger était connu
partout alors sans doute parce qu'il est
autrichien bien sûr ça c'est un
facteur
mais ce que je disais c'est que
l'agression la violence est un langage
mondial parce que nous sommes contraints
d'y réagir d'une manière ou d'une
autre n avons pas besoin de réagir à des
situations paisibles
pacifiqu et là c'est je dois dire c'est
un phénomène
transculturel
et je j'ai constaté une tendance dans
certains
pays les filles deviennent de plus en
plus violentes ça veut pas dire que les
garçons devien moins mais il est évident
que en général on pense que les filles
ne sont pas violentes et que les garçons
le sont et ça ça a évolué un peu il
faudrait bien sûr conduire une recherche
sur la
matière
les jeunes filles les jeunes femmes sont
plus enclin à s'adonner à la violence
qu'auparavant il y a des gangs de femmes
par exemple des bandes organisées de de
femmes ou de jeunes filles alors bien
sûr on peut toujours mettre sur la C
les médias en disant que ce sont les
bmissair
mais l'un dans
l'autre on peut dire de manière
générale que la
violence
diminue lors que les médias parlent
moins de violence montre moins de
violence alors il se peut que ce soit d
à d'autres causes dans certains pays
ceci dit on peut dire également que les
médias souvent ont des contenus
Pacifique en ce qui concerne les
contenus violents il y a effectivement
une
interaction alors à cette époque nous
avons constaté un résultat qui qui
sûrement perduré actuellement la
majorité des enfants qui ont été qui ont
fait l'objet de l'enquête peut-être à
voir avec la puberté ou pas mais la
majorité des enfants ont mentionné que
dans leur vie
quotidienne la violence était un
problème peut-être pas le problème
prédominant mais plus de de 70 % des
enfants ont affirmé qu'ils avaient des
problèmes de violence et que d'autre
part les leurs parents ne le savaient
pas vous avez dit que les parents
effectivement regardaient la télévision
avec leurs enfants mais n'utilisaient
guerre le avec les
enfants c'est la corrobore ce que j'ai
vu dans d'autres enquêtes dans d'autres
analyses pour les parents c'est beaucoup
plus un problème de maîtriser le
comportement de leurs enfants avec
l'ordinateur que avec la télévision donc
il jettent le Pr sur la télévision ou
l'ordinateur mais il ne contrôlent pas
vraiment le comportement de leur enfant
vis-à-vis des médias
le comportement des enfants vis-à-vis
des médias en fait et l'image du
comportement de leurs parents en général
les parents disent que c'est la faute
des médias mais ce sont eux qui donnent
l'exemple à leurs
enfants et ça c'est assez un phénomène
assez
intéressant
de plus on peut dire que l'impact des
médias que ce soit sur l'ordinateur ou à
la
télévision l'impact des médias ne peut
pas être considéré comme la seule cause
de la violence en revanche si l'on prend
en considération la combinaison de la
violence sur le terrain dans la vie
réelle la violence des médias et le
faible niveau de contrôle social là on
en vient à il en résulte un mélange
explosive partie de ce que je vous dis
peut-être retrouver dans certains
documents et il faut également examiner
les raisons pour lesquelles les gens
s'intéressent à la violence dans les
médias il s'agit aussi de la gestion des
humeurs si par exemple je
m'intéresse à la violence à la
télévision je m'adonne à des jeux vidéo
violents ça me remonte le moral c'est
bien pour mon humeur donc il faut voir
également quelles sont les raisons pour
lesquelles la violence dans les médias
est fascinante et surtout pour les
hommes et les garçons et si leses
enfants si ces garçons sont ont une
personnalité un peu faible à ce
moment-là ils chercheront des modèles à
imiter dans ce qu'il voi à la télévision
ou dans les jeux vidéos pour savoir
comment survivre dans un environnement
dangereux je ne vais pas vous parler de
cette diapo c'est trop scientifique
voilà une diapo très
intéressante voà l'opportunité de
regarder ce qui se passe dans les
différentses cultures les différents
niveaux de contrôle social et les
différents
niveaux de
violence c'est intéressant parce que
nous voyons que lorsque la violence dans
les médias est élevée ce qui a été est
toujours le cas au Japon et bien
simultanément le contrôle social est
très élevé
également et à ce moment-là il y a très
peu de violence dans la réalité il y a
un taux de suicide assez élevé au
Japon c'estàd l'agression est tournée
contre
soi-même en revanche
le jeu du contrôle social joue un rôle
majeur dans l'inhibition et dans le
refoulement de cette violence le
contrôle social est très à un niveau
très bas en revanche ne me demandez pas
quels sont les indicateurs scientifiques
que nous avons utilisé faites-moi
confiance nous avons utilisé beaucoup
donc si l'on
nassocie un niveau de violence dans les
médias élevés avec un niveau de contrôle
social bas et très
peu et et donc très peu de ô social
comme c'est le cas dans les favell
Brésiliennes une partie des États-Unis
une partie de l'Afrique du Sud on
aboutit à une combinaison un mélange
explosif alors évidemment la la violence
dans les médias joue un rôle déterminant
particulièrement pour ceux qui sont qui
qui
expérimentent une vraie violence dans
leur réalité ce n'est pas là une
caractéristique de nos pays comme les
Pays-Bas ou le Royaume-Uni ou la France
mais une un grand nombre de pays sont
véritablement violents dans la réalité
et donc le signal qui est donné aux
enfants si vous souhaitez survivre vous
devez utiliser la même violence que
celle que vous voyez dans les films
violents si le niveau de violence dans
les médias est relativement bas comme
c'est le cas en France et en Allemagne
heureusement nous pouvons subjectivement
penser que la violence est est
permanente dans nos médias mais par
rapport à tout est relatif par rapport à
ce qui se passe dans d'autres pays ce
n'est pas du tout le cas et il y a
d'autres formes de violence sur Internet
nous pouvons dire que la violence dans
nos médias est encore assez modérée dans
nos
pays donc peut-être devrait-on la
comparer à ce qui se passe au en Afrique
du Sud ou une partie des
États-Unis alors je ne sais pas si j'ai
le temps qui m'est imparti euh
est çaarrête non j'ai encore un peu de
temps bon parce que sinon il faudrait
utiliser de la violence à mon égard pour
m'arrêter donc comme je le disais je
suis peut-être un petit peu dans la
polémique mais si vous étudiez ce qui
s'est passé le weekend dernier aux
États-Unis et si en même temps euh vous
avez conduit comme moi certaines études
dans d'autres parties
du monde s'agit de savoir quelle est
l'influence négative préjudiciale de la
violence ou de la sexualité dans les
médias en général les Européens sont
assez choqués par les résultats il
semblerait qu'aux États-Unis par exemple
la violence dans les médias est perçu
comme moins dommageable que la sexualité
sur les écrans vous vous rappelez la
réaction à
au à l'exposition par Janet Jackson à la
télévision de ses de sa poitrine et cela
a suscité une levée de bouclier aux
États-Unis regardez ce qui s'est passé
ce qui se passe dans les programmes
télévisés ou les films américains il y a
pas mal de pruderie vous
voyez que là l'arrière-plan est assez
différent même chose lorsque l'on parle
de la question de la lutte contre les
armes à feu le port des armes à
feu une autre résultat de notre enquête
il est très difficile de de réduire la
violence et nous avons
constaté
que dans le monde islamique où nous
avons mené une enquête dans la plupart
des pays asiatiques et africains le pire
que l'on puisse faire à quelqu'un ce
n'est pas de l'agresser physiquement
c'est de lui lancer une insulte
psychologique ou religieuse
alors que dans le pays occidental le
pire c'est d'attaquer quelqu'un
physiquement pas de l'insulter alors
c'est l'inverse dans les pays certains
pays africain asiatique et surtout dans
le monde
musulman je
pense que si on avoir la question de
savoir comment gérer la question le
problème des religions diversités
culturell bien
sûr parler de la liberté d'expression
mais il faut bien comprendre quelles
sont les diversités culturelles alors
c'est pas exactement le sujet qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui mais je pense que
cela valit la peine de le mentionner
dans C dans ce cadre je vais tirer
quelques
conclusions bien sûr il faut éduquer les
médias bien sûr il faut donner plus de
pouvoir ou de il faut sensibiliser les
parents bien sûr mais nous devons
trouver un équilibre entre la
protection de la liberté
d'expression
et il faut pour cela prendre en
considération toute une série de
facteurs et en ce qui concerne cy ement
est-ce une question de liberté
d'expression nous ne savons pas d'autre
part lorsque j'ai présenté les résultats
de mon étude à un groupe pour le général
le Conseil général de
l'UNESCO et bien certaines
personnes qui n'é pas forcément d'accord
avec moi on on conclu que les médias ne
sont pas bons pour les enfants et qu'il
fallait totalement contrôler les médias
c'est qui est une bon alibé ou une bonne
excuse prétexte pour muser les médias je
crois que nous devons trouver un
équilibre entre le contrôle des médias
et le respect de la liberté d'expression
d'autre
part il faut donc trouver un équilibre
entre les deux
exigences et je
crois que pour ce faire nous devons
trouver une sorte de système
d'autoréglementation dont on peut rendre
compte c'està-dire avec un suivi il
s'agit de demander des comptes au aux
parties
prenantes donc ne va parler du
terrorisme vous pourrez le lire dans mon
document les enseignements que l'on a pu
tirer mais ce sera ma dernière diapo la
violence dans les médias est en fait
récompensée que ce soit l'agresseur dans
un film de fiction il a le pouvoir il
est en contrô
en général les victimes elles ne sont
pas récompensées il n'y a pas d'htoire
de fiction autour des victimes on n'a
pas envie d'entendre parler de
l'histoire des
victimes alors pourquoi la violence
est-elle si intéressante et bien parce
que elle récompense elle est gratifiante
pour l'agresseur c'est vrai de la
fiction mais également si vous
êtes membre d'une bande armée
ou un assassin vous apparaissez à la une
des journaux pas les
victimes alors l'exemple que nous avons
expérimenté ce weekend le prouve bien en
général tous les yeux font fixés sur
l'agresseur et non pas sur les
victimes c'est plus gratifiant entre
guillemets d'être l'agresseur que la
victime par conséquent très peu
d'attention consacrée à la
victime
et on peut ajouter
que la violence dans les médias a
des un impact mais un impact à grande
échelle nous ne parlons pas là de fait
d'impact statistiquement
significatif donc si nous avons la
violence sur le terrain plus un manque
de contrôle parental effectivement là
nous avons un problème avec la violence
dans les médias mais c'est un phénomène
complexe présent parlait de télévision
un peu de jeux de Vidéo et un peu de de
film de fiction maintenant nous avons la
la violence qui apparaît dans des
plateformes de communication qui ne peut
pas ne peuvent pas être contrôlé ou
difficilement il y a là une nouvelle
dimension qui s'ajoute nous sommes
entrés dans nouvel air ce qui est très
important euh les diffuseurs officiels
ont un impact de plus en plus faible il
faut bien le réaliser
je pense
que il y a des points de référence de
qualité comme on le souligne au sein de
l' peut-être au sein du Sénat par
exemple pour les diffuseurs
publics monsieurzone va nous en parler
d'ailleurs il s'agit là en fait d'une
tche d'ampleur internationale et
national il ne s'agit pas seulement des
médias ilut N sur les risques tout il
s'agit là bien sûr d'un chemin à
parcouru qui sera assez long
merci merci mon le professeur vous avez
fait une exposition très très très très
large et très intéressante qui nous a
posé beaucoup de
questions notamment dans dans certains
domaines sur lequel le Conseil de
l'Europe est particulièrement concerné
comme le dialogue interculturel euh la
nécessité de comprendre les différences
culturelles pour mieux comprendre les
phénomènes sociaux mais avant de me
enfin avant d'essayer de tirer des
conclusions de si brillantes
interventions qui ont été
faites évidemment jeouvre la discussion
le débat s'il y a des questions euh s'il
y a des
si quelquun veut poser des questions aux
intervenants et je revois déjà monsieuri
qui demande la parole
merci merci monieur le président notre
commission s'occupe de culture et de
sciences mais également de
sport jeoudrais poser une question au
rapporteur des SP
viol
la télévision d'État en Italie au cours
des derniers mois a interdit la
retransmission de
match de catch ou de lutte à l'heure de
grande écoute donc seulement après 22h
ces matchs peuvent être retransmis par
peur que les enfants puissent être
choqués après 22h les enfants sont
supposés
dormir est-ce que vous pensez
effectivement que le sport peut être
violent et peut également contribuer au
phénomène que N nous avons entendu
parler pour s'ajouter aux autres formes
de violence bon le catch les arts
martiaux sont des exemples de sport
violents merci merci Monsieur Santini je
donne maintenant la parole à Madame
abbler OK
esess et pu d'ailles question tous les
intervenant on parle de la relation
entre les médias et la
violence alors je voudrais savoir de
quelle violence on
parle
et c'est difficile de voir exactement le
lien entre la violence dans les médiia
et ces événements tragiques dans les
écoles il faut également parler de la
violence à l'encontre des minorités à
l'encontre des femmes
euh et le peu de soutien social qui
existe à l'encontre de pour lutter
contre ces violences al je voudrais
savoir également de quelle violence
parle-ton de quelle violence mesure-t-on
dans les
médias je suis moi-même enseignante
et souvent lorsque je discute avec mes
étudiants euh il me parle de ces talk
showows de ces débats à la
télévision vous connaissez également ces
émissions de télééalité où des gens sont
amenés à se s'insulter l'un l'autre à
s'umilier les uns les autres c'est une
forme également de violence que je
trouve beaucoup plus forte
surtout en ce qui concerne les jeunes
alors j'aimerais savoir si cela ajouter
jouer un rôle dans vos enquêtes
particulièrement la
téléréalité madamep vous avez
mentionné ou du moins c'est dans votre
document vous avez évoqué je crois
la violence dans les vidéos qui est
utilisée comme Ali par certains
agresseurs certains criminels qui se
cach derrière cet alibi lorsque il
s'agit de se défendre ils disent oui
mais ce n'est pas vraiment de ma faute
j'ai été incité par la violence dans les
jeux vidéos ou à la télévision c'est
donc une sorte de prétexte
d' merci
madameinger je passerai la parole après
à Madame nen et je propose que
ensuite
pardon et
ensuite et bien je demanderai aux
intervenants de répondre de répondre aux
questions qui auront été posé donc
Madame
merci moi je voudrais
remercier tous les intervenants pour
leur
exposés je voudrais
savoir si l'étude que vous aviez mené en
1999 avait été réactualisé si elle avait
été renouvelée si une nouvelle étude sur
cette question avait été menée à bien
éventuellement et je voulais savoir s'il
y avait une
corrélation
entre les handicaps d'apprentissage et
la
violence
notamment au vu de ce qui s'est passé à
Newtown le jeune qui a tué ses ses
enfants
semble avoir fait l'objet d'un
diagnostic notamment le syndrome
d'Asperger avez-vous dcelé des
corrélations entre
certains certaines perturbations
psychologiqu
et la violence voilà est-ce qu'il y a eu
des des études et j'étais très intéressé
également par le transparent que sur
lequel vous étiez passé rapidement sur
le terrorisme est-ce que vous pourriez
en dire de mot de
plus alors nous avons vu vous nous avez
bien montré l'impact de la violence sur
les enfants
mais je voudrais savoir s'il y avait des
études menées sur des mesures prévtives
on ne peut
pas faire en sorte que les les tous les
loisir tous les programmes de
divertissement soi totalement dénués de
violence il y aura toujours un certain
nombre de de modèles soit pe violent
mais que peut-on faire pour protéger les
enfants pour leur faire comprendre qu'il
s'agit d'illusion pour les
préparer et pour les préparer à ce type
d'exposition à ce type d'image merci
Madame vous si vous êtes d'accord je
passerai la parole il y a encore une
question de Monsieur conarti et je
passerai d'abord la parole à Monsieur
conarti pour poser sa question ensuite
vous
pourriez merci
beaucoup bon c'est quelque chose de très
basique hein ma
question je suis marié à une ancienne
directrice des services social et nous
avons un petit fils de 4 ans qui est
fasciné par
je sais pas si vous connaissez
ce ce ce cette émission et là on montre
des comportements tout à fait violent de
ce petit garçon contre sa sœur qui a 6
ans
et nous nous sommes des grands-parents
vigilants et donc nous avons essayé
d'étudier la question et nous avons vu
que les enfants en général étai un tout
petit peu plus agressifs après avoir vu
des jeux violents sur Internet ou
simplement en ayant vu ces petites
émissions c'est une
réaction souvent
physiologique ils sont excités en
quelque sorte par par ces jeux
et et on voit qu'à mainre reprise on
voit que les enfants commencent à
frapper commencent à frapper leurs
frères ou leurs sœurs alors un petit
enfant de 4 ans ma ma femme elle a un
Blackberry alors elle
regardait
les il a regardé les programmes sur sur
son BlackBerry et et il a il a il a
réussi à avoir accès à son BlackBerry à
des jeux qui étaient éventuellement et à
jouer avec et à jouer à ces jeux un
petit peu violent donc c'est très très
stimulant donc encore une fois ce n'est
pas uniquement de la violence
sous forme de passage à l'acte mais on
voit que les enfants sont très très
stimulés et deviennent et deviennent
agressifs donc je ne suis pas sûr que
les que notamment les les premiers
orateurs fassent grand cas de cela
et nous nous pensons que si les enfants
grandissent dans
ce en ayant un accès si facile à la
violence et ben quels adultes vont-ils
devenir merci Monsieur
Benton
merci et merci également pour vos
contributions alors j'étais en train de
réfléchir ce que j'avais entendu et il
me semble que le problème ce n'est pas
le ce n'est pas le fait que la violence
soit montrée à la télévision pas
seulement bon c'est la quantité les
volumes de violence le leur densité le
le nombre d'occurrence des cas de
violence c'est ça le grand problème et
pourquoi je dis ça
mais
je me souviens d'un temps où les enfants
étaient contrôlés
et ils
écoutai même des programmes de radio moi
je me souviens que ma que ma mère ma
chère mère me
disait me disait non non non tu ne vas
pas écouter ça parce que ça ne va rien
t'apprendre et d'autres certains pourrai
qualifier ça de de censure moi je pense
que ce n'est pas véritablement de la
censure
c'était c'est ce que nous devons
également à nos enfants tout simplement
de quelqu pays que nous soyons je pense
que nous devons cela à nos enfants nous
devons cette forme d'encadrement nous
devons essayer
de de suivre de près tout simplement ce
qu'il regarde dans notre monde
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
n'est je ne pense pas
que telle ou telle action tel ou tel
geste va empêcher un enfant d'avoir
accès à la violence à des scènes de
violence parce que tout simplement nous
avons télévision mais la violence B
elle n'est pas
forcément la violence c'est pas
forcément ce qui se passe là con ce que
vous avez vécu il y a 20 ans mais
la violence c'est pas seulement ça la
violence et l'injustice notamment dans
le monde entier dans les pays en
développement la pauvreté pour moi c'est
ça aussi la
violence alors souligner ça d'un côté
et attirer notre
attention sur d'autres formes de
violence
bon c'est autre chose donc encore une
fois je moi franchement je pense
que je pense qu'encore une fois ce sont
ce ne sont pas véritablement les les
formes de violence auquelle on assiste
qui sont préjudiciables mais c'est le
l'ampleur de cette violence à laquelle
on assiste pas d'autres demandes de
parole il n'y a pas d'autres questions
je pense qu'on a déjà un ensemble de
questions assez riches assez il y a il y
a vraiment un
toute toute une un bon un bon
euh matière à réflexion donc je
demanderai je pense qu'on pourrait
peut-être donner la parole par ordre on
pourrait enverser l'ordre précédente et
je pense que tout le monde a des
questions à répondre des questions ont
été posées en général d'autres ont été
posé un ont été posés en particulier à à
à à certaines à certains intervenants
donc ce que je propose c'est on on peut
procéder à l'envers je commencerai par
le monsieur Grobel ensuite madame Ramou
et finalement madame tipfel et euh vous
vous dans vos interventions je vous
demanderai de tenir compte de toutes
enfin de de toutes les questions qui ont
été posées et particulièrement celles
qui vous ont été directement adressées
évid
c'est très dangereux de me laisser
commencer bon
brièvement c'est pas l'ordre dans lequel
les question on été posées mais
l'injustice dans le monde effectivement
c'est fondamental bien sûr
cependant pour pour aller au-delà un
petit peu de la question des
médias il y
a une théorie c'est l'hypothèse de la
frustration agression là vous êtes sers
d'accord avec moi que plus les personnes
sont
frustrées plus grande est la est la
probabilité de devenir agressif c'est
très très
simple si on commence à titiller
quelqu'un et bien ça rend les gens
agressifs tout simplement maintenant
lorsque l'on parle de l'injustice dans
le monde et je pense que vous m'avez
parlé également du terrorisme il y a une
idée simple c'est que plus la situation
est injuste pour
personnes plus ils en viennent
ouvertement au terrorisme est-ce que
c'est vrai j'ai beaucoup étudié le
terrorisme par le passé mais
malheureusement c'est pas aussi simple
ce que l'on trouve en général c'est que
les leaders les dirigeants terroristes
ne sont pas véritablement des gens qui
vivent dans des dans des milieux
défavorables mais ils savent comment
utiliser la pauvreté et l'injustice
pour lancer leurs attaques c'est pour ça
que je peux mentionner cette question du
terrorisme les médias pendant très
longtemps peut-être que ça change un
petit peu mais pendant longtemps les
grandes médias
notamment au moment du 11
septembre ne comprenit pas ce qui se
passait parce que l'objectif principal
des terroristes c'était de
créer
créer évidemment de
de la dévastation de blesser de tuer des
gens mais le plus important pour eux
c'était d'attirer l'attention des médias
donc d'avoir un pouvoir de contrôler la
situation de contrôler notamment les
médias donc est-ce que l'injustice
entraine automatiquement l'agression et
le terrorisme ce n'est pas aussi simple
maintenant
vous avez parlé de l'ampleur de la
violence de la
quantité alors je ne connais pas
d'études qui montreraient une relation
de cause à effet
entre par
exemple le nombre de d'émissions avec
des du sport agressif ou du catch et
cetera et la violence alors évidemment
certains sports peut-être
entraîne certains degré d'excitation qui
entraîent à leur tour certaines
réactions cependant si on parle de la
quantité de contenu violent et agressif
et bien on peut voir
que il est moins probable qu'il y ait
moins d'autres contenus et si je regarde
par exemple une
télévision une
émission des émissions violentes tout
journée et bien il y a moins de
probabilité que je regarde d'autres
contenus par exemple que j'apprenne
qu'il existe d'autres solutions au
règlement des conflits bon c'est tout
simple mais il faut quand même aborder
ça sous cet
angle les médias violents
ne sont pas pédagogique mais au moins
cela dit ah vous voyez vous avez une
solution très très simple pour régler
vos problèmes euh
et c'est lié d'ailleurs à la théorie de
l'apprentissage sociale que vous avez
mentionné donc c'est très gratifiant
c'est récompens on a une
solution rapide et simple à vos
problèmes donc je suis pas d'accord pour
dire par exemple le simple fait de
regarder du catch ou de la lutte ça rend
les gens violents
non maintenant vous avez parlé de
d'agression psychologique comme dans les
reality show le harcèlement les insultes
et cetera est-ce que ça a un effet bon
moi j'aurais tendance à dire
que et ça peut-être un impact sur la
façon dont nous interagissons les uns
avec les autres cela ne nous incite pas
forcément à la violence mais cela nous
permet peut-être
de de penser que insulter les gens après
tout c'est pas si grave que ça
ensuite estce est que cette étude de
l'UNESCO a
été renouvelée vous savez ça a été très
très compliqué à faire et M moi j'aurais
adoré j'aurais adoré la renouveler mais
ça coûte très très cher c'est très
compliqué à organiser
mais c une
étude qui j'en suis sûr arriverait à peu
près au même résultat aujourd'hui
peut-être à quelques nuances près mais
l'impact de contrôle social de valeur
sociale la combination de
dans les médias et de la violence dans
la réalité et de ses effets je pense que
en gros en gros dans ces grandes lignes
les effets seraient les mêmes et si vous
me le permettez j'aimerais juste ajouter
une chose c'est que en essayant
d'étudier les motivations nous avons
essayé de nous avons vu que les enfants
qui vient dans un environnement
paisible ne servent pas du contenu
violent pour en tirer des enseignements
pour leur propre comportement ils s'en
servent pour être exciter en quelque
sorte dans un environnement un petit peu
ennuyeux disons ça ça les excite mais
dans un environnement violent et bien à
ce momentlà ils en tirent directement
des conséquences des enseignements
pratiques là il faut établir une
distinction et
enfin et ça je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec cela effectivement effectivement
c'est vrai que l'effet de la
violence des médias
ne vient pas uniquement du contenu mais
c'est inextricablement lié à au besoin
d'excitation il y a des professeurs en
Alabama notamment qui ont beaucoup
travaillé sur l'excitation
et qui a montré
que
les l'excitation venant de la violence
dans un environ violent implique de la
violence donc là le rôle de l'excitation
est très très important oui
effectivement oui et dernière chose
dernière
chose j'avais dit que j'en avais un
petit peu assez de travailler sur ces
questions de l'agression peut-être moi
aussi je commence à m'habituer à la
violence je suis victime du syndrome
d'habituation et je vois quel effet ça
peut avoir sur la société si je le
ressens déjà sur moi voilà je vais
m'arrêter là
bon je ne pense pas que vous ayez été
ennuyux en tout cas vous-même mais
maintenant j'ai le plaisir de donner la
parole à ma compatriote le
professur et donc je lui demande
répondre au plusieurs questions qui ont
été
adressé
merci en ce qui concerne les types de
violence dans les
médias dans notre
étude nous n'avons pas obseré observé
uniquement la violence
physique et nous avons vu que la
violence
psychologique avait des conséquences
parfois plus négatives que la violence
physique la violence physique
et et verbal était corrélé
insulte taper quelqu'un en l'insultant
nous avons essayé d'établir des
corrélations nous avons essayé de voir
ce que les enfants et les jeunes
regardaient à la télévision et sur
Internet mais nous avons essayé de voir
quels ét le type de comportement qu'
adopt à
l'école et là nous avons observé non
seulement la violence direct que le
harcèlement mais type de
violence au recours un certain nombre de
jeunes sur Internet au
téléphone et ce de plus en plus de tous
les jours on entend parler de
d'exemples de cyber violence de cyber
harcèlement et ça ça semble être plus
proiminant encore que la violence
directe
physique maintenant ce qui concerne la
prévention
possible ce que l'on voit à la
télévision sur Internet on le sait on
sait que ça peut être
assimilé et ainsi la violence peut être
considéré comme un moyen de régler les
problèmes et donc le reprendre à son
compte et là les parents les enseignants
ont un rôle fondamental à jouer mais
uniquement uniquement s'ils ont
conscience de cela et s'ils savent
comment comment appréhender ces nouveaux
médias et comment transmettre ces
valeurs à leurs
enfants notamment par leurs attitudes
qu'il leur apprennent non seulement à à
se servir les des médias bon c'est ce
que les parents font quand même
régulièrement
mais il faut essayer de comprendre ce
que l'on voit à l'écran et essayer
d'interpréter correctement ce que l'on
voit à l'écran donc encore une fois il
s'agissait d'une étude pilote une étude
exploratoire donc pour l'instant n
pouvons pas véritablement dire donc je
passe la parole maintenant à Madame
Astrid sipfel pour répondre aux
questions posé
par
merci tout d'AB au au sujet du
sport lien entre sport et la
violence et
bien certain temps on commencé les
recherche expérimental et souvent on
essayait de regarder ce qui se passait
pour les spectateurs de box et puis on a
laissé tomber parce que ça
nepporte rien tout simplement parce que
dans le port il y a des règles dans la
box il y a des règles euh
dans d'autres types de sport on sait
qu'il y a des limites on sait qu'il y a
des conditions il y a des règles à
suivre et c'est pour cela que je pense
que c'est très très
différent et ce n'est pas ça qui
comporte le plus de risque il y a des
études qui
montrent que le catch ou la lutte
pourrait éventuellement avoir des effets
délitaires mais les résultats montrent
que les effets sont faibles à modéré
qu'ils ne sont pas pas véritablement
important maintenant il y a une autre
chose c'est quand des sportif
connus ont des attitudes violentes ça
c'est autre chose quand un footballeur
connu est violent qu'il n'est pas
sanctionné et bien là là c'est un risque
mais pas le sport en
général la deuxème question pait sur
d'autres types de violence la violence
verbale la violence indirecte
et là la recherche ne fait que commencer
sur ces
sujetsl il y a déjà un certain nombre
d'études qui montrent il y a des effets
effectivement sur la violence
verbale la violence psychologique peut
être très très déléire et c'est très
très important d'étudier ces effets
parce que la recherche montre que une
violence exercée par les femmes diffère
de celle exercée par les hommes il y a
différents types de
violences et qui ne que l'on ne retrouve
pas dans les études parce que trop
souvent on se concentre sur la violence
physique or les femmes ont parfois
recours à d'autres types de violence ce
n'est pas la forme de violence préférée
des femmes c'est pour cela qu'il n'y a
pas encore assez d'études mais il semble
qu'il y ait des effets
déjà maintenant en ce qui concerne
l'argument selon
lesquels les les délinquants ou les
criminels se défausse sur les
médias et kunchck et mon collègue et
moi-même nous avons travaillé sur Cees
sujets et lui il a mené une étude il y a
une quinzaine d' une quinzaine d'années
c'était une enquête auprès des des des
juges et on leur demandait est-ce
que vousz rencontré souvent ce type
d'argument et ce type d'argument
effectivement on les rencontre de
personnes qui disent c'est pas moi c'est
les
médias
et si je me souviens bien je n pas les
chiffres en tête mais bon maintenant
maintenant c'est ces arguments même si
c'est des stratégies qui sont adoptées
par certains délinquants certains
criminels qui cherchent des excuses ce
ne sont pas du tout des stratégies et
qui sont porteuses pour leur défense en
tout cas en ce qui concerne les
déficites
d'apprentissage là je ne suis pas
expert sur ce type de
trouble
mais il n'y a pas véritablement de
corrélation entre l'intelligence les
capacités d'apprentissage et les effets
de la violence il n'y en a
pas s'il y a si on trouve de telles
corrélations c'est qu'il y a également
un contexte
social qui qui est et il y a parfois
également le trouble de la tension qui
peut jouer et
mais tout ça est toujours lié au
contrôle du contrôle du comportement
donc des gens qui ont du mal à contrô du
mal à contrôler leur comportement et
ceux sont peut-être plus enclin à agir
violemment mais c'est un effet que je
qualifierai
d'indirect en ce qui concerne la
prévention je pense que nous allons
peut-être en entendre parler dans la
deuxè séance il y a des étud empiri qui
qui montrent que la médiation des
parents peut jouer peut prévenir des
effets
négatifs
quand les enfants son sont sensibilisés
à la perspective de la au point de vue
de la
victime et si les parents commentent
négativement ce que l'on montre à la
télévision c'est pas seulement le fait
de regarder ensemble un certain nombre
de programmes mais il faut que les
parents commentent réagissent de façon
négative à certains actes de violence et
qu' donne les raisons de cette
réaction
à l'école
également si les élèves sont très
impliqués dans des études ou dans des
dans des dans des cours qui montre la
violence de façon négative et bien je
pense que ça peut être en ce qui concne
l'excitation
l'excitation peut
représenter des contenus violents comme
l'a dit le professeur différents
contenus peuvent exciter des
télpectateurs par exemple les enfants
peuv être excité et
par des par des documents qui ne sont
pas forcément violents par exemple par
quelque chose de très rapide
très fort et les enfants
souvent quand ils imitent quelque chose
quand ils imitent ce qu'ils ont vu à la
télévision ils ne l'mitent pas forcément
parce que c'est de l'agression il ne
pens pas que c'est l'agression
simplement parce qu'ils ont vu que ça
les a excité donc il faut juste leur
montrer que que ce type de comportement
type de comportement n'est pas
socialement acceptable donc c'est il est
très très important
d'intervenir au bon
moment donc si on leur explique que ce
n'est pas bien je pense que ça peut ça
peut
fonctionner et
enfin en ce qui
concerne l'ampleur de cette violence en
tant que
chercheur je dois dire
que la quantité non plus n'a pas est en
elle-même un effet déléire oui
effectivement si vous passez beaucoup de
temps à regarder violent évidemment
euh ça peut pas être forcément bien mais
c'est plus le contexte c'est
vraiment
plus que la quantité et la densité c'est
le contexte dans lequel se passe C
visionnage cette exposition à la
violence ça c'est beaucoup plus
important même si c'est une idée qui est
peut-être moins populaire mais c'est ce
que montre la recherche en tout cas je
vais
maintenant donner la parole
à
ensuite le professeur grber V rajouter
quelque
chose merci merci pour toutes ces
interventions qui m'ont tout à fait
passionné je off une transition entre
cette session et la
prochaine j'ai passé les 21 premières
années de ma vie à préparer des
programmes de télévision produire des
programmes de télévision pour les
adultes et enfant alors dans ce contexte
j'ai fait pas mal d'études sur l'impact
de ce que nous
diffusions sur les
téléspectateurs et là bien sûr il s'agit
d'un passé asse
lointain alors pour ceux qui disent bon
tout cela n'a pas vraiment
d'effet mais alors si ça n'a pas d'effet
pourquoi est-ce que il y a des
entreprises qui payent pour faire passer
leur
publicité bien sûr que la publicité a un
effet sur les téléspectateurs et bien
sûr les autres programmes de télévision
ont un effet sur les téléspectateurs la
violence remonte également au début des
médias
audiovisuels Tom jry les dessin
animp j é assz violent pour ce d'entre
vous qui sont ass pour souvenir plus
récemment James Bond c'est assez violent
également
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse assurer que
ces d animés un effet
préjudicial mention le phénomène
d'habitude
d'accout etsur a parlé de l'effet
psychologique et c'est là où rés nos
préoccupations
au temps des de la guerre en Irlande du
Nord à la télévision on commençait
toujours par hier
soir encore un soldat un soldat de plus
a été tué C c'était quasiment tous les
jours qu'on entendait cela et bien en
dépit de notre sensibilité en tant que
téléspectateur nous sommes devenus
habitué à ce genre de nouvell lors des
troubles de l'Irlande du Nord
et plus récemment des cadavres sont
revenus de
militair et de
l'Afghanistan
et là encore nous y sommes
habitués il y a également l'impact
psychologique qui est beaucoup plus
subliminal et donc à mon sens beaucoup
plus dangereux que un P là que l'on voit
entre James Bond et son ennemi à
l'écran c'est un impact d'ailleurs qui
s'exerce non seulement sur l'enfant mais
sur les
adultes voilà pour ce colloque sur la
violence dans les médias et ses
conséquences sur les enfants et la
société si vous souhaitez le revoir
notre site internet public senena.fr
bonne journée à
tous